bien mes chers collègues nous allons
poursuivre nos travaux madame madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir ce matin pour la
première fois la nouvelle secrétaire
d'État chargée de la biodiversité Sarah
et Madame la Ministre votre portefeuille
évolue passant du service national
universitaire à la bio aniversel à la
biodiversité ce changement d'attribution
vous conduit par conséquence à
intervenir devant n ce dont nous nous
félicitons en matière de biodiversité et
de développement durable notre
commission a acquis au cours de ces 10
années d'existence une indéniable
expertise et un regard assérer sur les
enjeux
environnementaux vous avez devant vous
des sénateurs qui ont notamment œuvré
pour faire la loi climat et résilience
d'Out 21 un cadre nominatif ambitieux
ambitieux réaliste juste socialement et
promouvoir des politiques public qui
mettent les élus locaux et les
territoires au centre du jeu car ce sont
de véritables laboratoires de la
transition
écologique sur chaque texte soumis à son
examen la commission marque de son
empreinte pragmatique les dispositions
permettant d'atteindre les objectifs
climatiques et environnementaux de notre
pays dans un souci d'équité et de
justice sociale sans rien céder à la
nécessaire ambition qui doit
caractériser nos politiques publiques en
la matière m ministre où en sommesnous
aujourd'hui en matière de
odiversité la
situation malgré des plans stratégiques
mis en œuvre par les gouvernements
successif ne npparaît pas
particulièrement brillante l'érosion de
la biodiversité se poursuit à un rythme
soutenu et le déclin des espèces et
malheureusement une réalité tangible
toutes les études le prouvent chiffre
préoccupant à à l'appui il s'agit là
d'une mauvaise nouvelle pour tout le
monde dans le cadre de d'un nouveau au
cadre mondial d'action a été fixé en
décembre à l'occasion de la COP 15
biodiversité à laquelle a participé une
délégation de la commission composée de
Guillaume
chevrolier de Denis SAÉ et notre ancien
collègue Jean-Michel houlgat sans
oublier Renand Dantec cette séquence de
diplomatie environnementale a permis
l'adoption d'un cadre mondial ambitieux
et nous l'espérons transformateur pour
la biodiversité à l'horizon 2030
l'accord de kununing à Montréal fixe un
cap cap déterminant les objectifs et
prévoit une méthode d'évaluation
d'atteindre des objectifs afin de
corriger les trajctoire si celles-ci ne
permettent pas l'inversion de la
tendance en matière d'érosion et de
biodiversité près d'un an plus tard où
on est la France dans la transposition
de ce cadre et le financement de
celui-ci la stratégie nationale pour la
biodiversité a-t-elle été redimensionnée
à l'Ô de ces nouveaux objectifs les
moyens budgétaires allués au programme
d'action sont-ils à la hauteur du défi
colossal en la matière quelle est votre
feuille de route pour faire de la SNB
une stratégie gagnante contrairement à
toutes les stratégies précédente autant
de réponses que j'aimerais que vous
apportiez madame la ministre pour ouvrir
le débat avant de laisser la parole ou à
mes nombreux collègues euh qui se sont
déjà inscrits euh pour préciser à
travers leurs questions les réponses que
vous ne manquerez pas le rapporter le
rapporter je vous cède la parole madame
la ministre merci beaucoup euh monsieur
le prés président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames messieurs moi je suis très
heureuse d'être aujourd'hui auditionné
dans votre commission puisque c'est la
première audition avec ma nouvelle mon
nouveau portefeuille celui de la
biodiversité même si en réalité il y a
une continuité entre jeunesse et et
biodiversité puisque dans le fond on
passe d'un défi de société celui de
créer de l'unité entre entre une
génération et lui préserver en tout cas
lui préserver un capital environnemental
lui permettant mine de rien de vivre
dans un environnement qui est dur
et pour ça monsieur le monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs vous MZ demandé trois choses
d'une certaine manière en trois temps la
première c'est de faire un état des
lieux ensuite de dire en quoi la
stratégie nationale biodiversité est a
été travaillée retravaillée ou en quoi
elle répondrait aux enjeux en tout cas
du moment que nous vivons et enfin
est-ce que la question budgétaire est à
la hauteur de la stratégie écrite et en
tout cas après avoir reçu un certain
nombre d'avis donc je commencerai
monsieur le Président par les à des
lieux ce qui est certain c'est que la
situation elle est préoccupante et vous
le savez vous le savez tous elle est
préoccupante pour plusieurs raisons les
quelques chiffres sont que nous donnons
régulièrement sont quand même assez
assez impactants on a la chance d'avoir
un patrimoine naturel en France qui peut
nous rendre fier c'est 10 % des espèces
qui sont connues sur la planète mais du
coup ça nous engage d'une certaine
manière à être à la hauteur de la
protection et de la préservation on a à
peu près 600 nouvelles espèces qui sont
décrites tous les jours euh et en
majorité dans nos outres mers ce qui
apporte une richesse et un regard très
spécifique à à apporter d'ailleurs ça a
été une des améliorations sur la
stratégie nationale biodiversité qui a
été nécessaire euh nous avons d'une
certaine manière et je crois que c'est
le c'est le plus impactant euh
conscience que nous vivons un
effondrement nous vivons le 6e
effondrement du vivant c'est 1 million
d'espèces qui sont aujourd'hui menacées
on parle de la 6e extinction euh de
masse euh c'est à peu près 12000 espèces
connues en France qui sont euh qui sont
touchées ce qui est ce qui est certain
c'est que la biodiversité c'est la base
de tous les besoins humains c'est un
écosystème assez large alors quand on
pose la question très simplement de
qu'est-ce que la biodiversité je suis sû
tout le monde ne pose n'apporte pas la
même définition c'est pas très grave
dans le fond la biodiversité c'est les
vivants je vais le mettre au pluriel
c'est la faune la flore bien sûr mais en
réalité tous les écosystème qui
permettent aussi le la préservation de
de cette faune et de cette flore c'est
aussi tous les services gratuitement
rendu par par la nature de manière
immatérielle je pense évidemment à la
photosynthèse à la pollinisation à la
filtration je sais que vous sortez d'un
d'unun d'une présentation d'un rapport
sur l'eau qui montre à quel point la
purification de l'eau est absolument
essentiel mais aussi l'absorption des
chocs climatiques puisque aujourd'hui la
biodiversité c'est la victime du
dérèglement climatique en fait c'est
aussi une partie de la solution puisque
il y a un certain nombre de réponses qui
sont basées sur la nature elle-même et
je ne peux pas je ne peux pas terminer
euh la définition de la biodiversité
sans parler de quelque chose en tout cas
qui me tient particulièrement à cœur
c'est aussi la préservation d'un
patrimoine immatériel qui est la beauté
de nos paysages euh et d'une certaine
manière la beauté euh de nos
territoirees et comment on la préserve
on les préserve euh partout et au plus
proche en terme de proximité c'est aussi
une garantie pour notre monde et notre
système économique c'est 44 milliards
euh de dollars c'est la moitié du pays
PIB mondial et cet effondrement mais
autant en danger en réalité la
préservation de nos modes de vie que le
vivant que les questions de santé que la
préservation de notre propre prospérité
comme des les élus au plus près de chez
eux et moi je je suis d'abord avant
enfin avant d'être parlementaire je suis
d'abord élu local euh on se préoccupe
tous de la qualité de l'eau de sa
quantité on se préoccupe tous de de nos
zones humide on se préoccupe tous de
comment on peut adapter nos territoires
face à ces des règlements climatiques
qui qui font que nos paysages changent à
vue d'œil et donc face à ce dérèglement
euh moi j'adorais que l'bè qui est leog
de la biodiversité soit aussi connu il a
pas encore cette la même notoriété mais
il a Libes a posé un constat très clair
qui nous permet de travailler de manière
très pragmatique c'est les cinq
pressions si on veut parler de
biodiversité on peut parler des cinq
pressions et ensuite il faut réduire la
pression une par une ce qui est
important c'est que ces pressions par
d'importance c'est évidemment les
changements d'usage sur terre et sur mer
la surexploitation des ressources ça
c'est assez c'est assez évident le
changement climatique qui du coup
intègre la biodiversité plus globalement
de la planification les pollutions elles
sont diverses les intrans mais aussi la
pollution lumineuse sonore enfin c'est
les pollutions pluriel les espèces
exotiques envahissantes qu'on connaît
sur un certain nombre de nos cours d'eau
mais
aussi pendant l'été pour parler rien que
du Moustic tigre en particulier qui a
créé pas mal de de de questionnement sur
la question de la
santé enfin j'arrive à la question que à
la deuxième que vous avez posé monsieur
le Président sur la stratégie nationale
biodiversité elle a comme objectif et
c'est posé et fixé par la première
ministre d'abord de stopper
l'effondrement donc de travailler sur
les cinq pressions et de les réduire et
ensuite d'inverser l'effondrement donc
de restaurer pour réduire les cinq
pressions évidemment on a pris point par
point ce que je disais les CIN points
ensuite la restauration d'un d'une
biodiversité dégradée pour la rendre
plus résiliente pour ça si je devais
pour y arriver on avait besoin de deux
conditions nouvelles en tout cas qu'on
avait pas spécialement dans les dans
dans les anciens plans la mobilisation
de tous les acteurs si on n' pas de
mobilisation d'acceptabilité d'éducation
à la question environnemental si les
entreprises ne se mouillent pas si ell
n'intègrent pas le diagnostic sur leur
dépendance ça reste partiel quoi ça
reste partiel ou bien on fait porter la
charge sur en réalité qu'une partie de
ceux qui ont un certain nombre de clés
et donc c'est la mobilisation de tous
les acteurs et puis le deuxième le
deuxième et le le dernier la dernière
condition nécessaire c'est pour garantir
d'atteindre les objectifs il faut des
moyens des moyens de financement
historiques ça c'est clair mais aussi
des moyens avec des indicateurs et de
l'évaluation parce que beaucoup trop et
puis moi je l'ai vu dans les un certain
nombre d'auditions me disent au bout de
quelques quelques années bah finalement
vous êtes donné des plans mais enfin
vous les avez pas atteint et il s'est
rien passé entre temps je je je dis
comme je l'ai entendu donc je je le mets
évidemment entre entre guillemets pour
ça la stratégie nationale elle va
d'abord lutter contre les causes alors
il y a un projet il y a des projets
d'air protégé il y a la lutte contre la
préservation des habitats il y a les
questions de gestion adaptative sur la
surxploitation la lutte contre les
pollutions
plastiques les espèces exotiques
envillissantes je pourrais rentrer dans
le détail pendant les questions pour pas
être trop longue dans les propos
liminires mais le deuxème axe qui
consiste à restaurer ne se fait pas par
une simple décision de l'État enfin
soyons très clair ça se fait avec une
mobilisation des territoires et donc
d'une certaine manière que ce soit les
intercommunalités ou que ce soit le bloc
communal bloc départemental ou au niveau
régional c'est les trames écologiques
c'est la restauration et la renaturation
des villes dans les zones les plus
urbaines c'est le PACT haie avec les
50000 km de haie c'est la restauration
de nos zones humides et on sait à quel
point il faut un certain nombre de fonds
c'est la question de la forêt qui
aujourd'hui en France va pas très bien
enfin si on dit les choses de manière un
peu un peu claire
évidemment la France sur la scène
internationale puisque vous avez parlé
des accords de Cunningham monéal
monsieur le Président porte également et
soutient encore aujourd'hui l'adoption
du règlement européen sur la
restauration de la nature avec voilà
avec ambition mais de manière mesurable
parce que porter des ambitions sans des
évaluations régulières aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus possible pour mobiliser
l'ensemble des acteurs nous avons besoin
d'abord de travailler avec les
collectivités au premier premier chef
c'est pour ça que cette stratégie
nationale
a en réalité pas un volet mais une mise
en œuvre totale qui sera territorialisée
et c'est cette territorialisation qui
permettra de répondre au plus près soit
des opportunités soit des difficultés il
faut également mobiliser les entreprises
via leur dépendance et la connaissance
de leur dépendance mais aussi la
question de la gestion de l'eau et de la
sobriété sur la consommation d'eau et
enfin les citoyens parce qu' alors c'est
Coustau qui disait ça mais alors on aime
ce qui nous émerveille et on protège ce
que l'on aime donc dans le fond si on
arrive à émerveiller nos enfants avec
des aires éducatives avec de l'éducation
et bien je j'ai la conviction qu'on peut
aller beaucoup plus loin cette
territorialisation dont je parlais qui
est d'une certaine d'une certaine
manière la mre des batailles à mes yeux
cette territorialisation elle s'inscrit
dans la planification écologique elle
sera également portée avec Christophe
Béchu pendant les cops régionales qui
permettront de poser un certain nombre
de
diagnostics et pour aller même plus plus
en détail on peut aller jusqu'à
l'échelle communale avec l'atlace de la
biodiversité euh communale où on
apprécie la biodiversité on la qualifie
et ensuite bah ça facilite les actions
en faveur je sais le je connais le point
de financement sur cettel la
biodiversité l'investisement que ça
demande aujourd'hui ça peut être porté
jusqu'à 80 % mais enfin reste toujours
euh les moyens à mettre en œuvre et je
sais qu'il y a plus de communes qui ont
postulé aujourd'hui et candidaté que de
communes qui ont pu être accompagné le
dernier axe je le disais c'est
maintenant les moyens et ces moyens ils
sont euh euh ils sont important c'est 10
milliards d'euros supplémentaires dans
le cadre de la planification écologique
tout sujet confondu 1,2 milliards plus
spécifiquement sur biodiversité et dans
biodiversité il y a préservation de
l'eau et biodive 475 millions sur plan
haut 400 millions supplémentaires sur la
stratégie en tant que telle biodiversité
300 millions pour les friches euh et
enfin 100 millions pour des fonds de
renaturation pour vous donner euh une
idée cette année il y a eu 12700
dossiers qui ont été déposés pour
12,7 milliards en réalité d'euros et il
y avait 431 millions seuls dans la dans
la stratégie biodiversité hors
renouvellement des friches parce que
pour le coup les questions de
dépollution et et de renaturation sont
particulière j'espère que la haute la
haute assemblée qui est la vôtre
renforcera le fond vert de 500 millions
supplémentaire en tout cas je l'espère
très très sincèrement en particulier sur
un projet qui permet de réhabiliter et
surtout de naturer les les écoles avec
permettant de faire de la
désimperméabilisation ou encore la
création d'ilot de de fraîcheur que ce
soit sur les toits que ce soit que ce
soit sur les façades donc des moyens
renouvelés mais une bataille en tout cas
je je pense que je peux pas conclure mes
propos sans en parler la place de la
science et de la connaissance dans dans
dans cet ensemble en tout cas dans ce
défi défi du siècle puisque aujourd'hui
plus que jamais nous avons besoin de ces
indicateurs on sait que sur la question
du climat parce que il y a le cûp de la
tonne carbone parce que parce que il y a
des
il y a des trajectoires qu'on arrive à
suivre c'est peut-être plus facile ce
qui est certain c'est que la
biodiversité on a besoin de vulgariser
on a besoin de science participative on
a besoin de ne pas
opposer progrès et préservation et pour
ça il faut des gouvernance à la hauteur
et pour faire évoluer ces gouvernances
et bien c'est tout le travail qui est
fait aujourd'hui de manière
interministérielle sous évidemment la
tutelle de la première ministre et du
ministre de l'Environnement avec quelque
chose d'assez nouveau qui est le
secrétaire général à la planification le
sgpe qui sincèrement est un enin met de
du vent dans les voiles si vous me
permettez l'expression peut-être un peu
plus populaire mais enfin ça ça change
quand même la donne moi j'ai été pendant
3 ans au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et l'interministérialité sur
les questions de jeunesse était
peut-être plus difficile au quotidien
parce que il fallait aller la chercher
une par une là on a des rendez-vous où
cette interministérialité est évaluée et
sincèrement je je vois en tout cas la
différence mais pour avoir une stratégie
qui tienne la route et bien nous avons
évidemment construit et coconstruit et
nous avons reçu les avis de des quatre
instances qui ont été saisies plus
spécifiquement le Comité national de
l'eau le Conseil national des maires et
des des Maes et des littoraux le Conseil
national de la protection de la nature
et enfin le Comité National biodiversité
qui a réuni qui réunit à lui seul 143
membres neuf collèges donc on a pu avoir
une vision globale collectivité
agriculteur monde économique association
ça donnait vraiment des des avis assez
complets et donc la version définitive
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs sera présentée dans
quelques semaines donc le temps de
stabiliser l'ensemble des avis mais ce
qui est certain et en conclusion la
situation de la nature aujourd'hui et du
vivant exige des action d'ampleur on a
des moyens budgétaires qui sont nouveaux
et qui sont d'ampleur et c'est pour ça
que pour réussir nous avons besoin de la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des élus qui
font la force de notre pays voilà
monsieur le Président de liminaire une
la trajectoire qui m'a été
donnée merci madame la ministre je vais
donner la parole à notre rapporteur
budgétaire Guillaume chevrelier et puis
j'ai 16 demandes de parole donc si on
pouvait se limiter à à une minute une
minute et demi de question ça fait 17 ça
fait 17 souit à demande de parole à une
minute une minute et demi ce serait bien
alors ça fait 19 maintenant ça fait 19
voilà Monsieur le rapporteur guum vous
avez la paroleés je prendrai un peu plus
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
madame la ministre après la la jeunesse
vous avez la biodiversité effectivement
un vaste sujet dans dans le contexte de
la 6e extinction de masse comme l'a
indiqué notre Président dans son propos
introductif une délégation de notre
commission a participé l'année dernière
à la COP 15 biodiversité cette COP a
abouti à l'adoption d' d'un accord cadre
mondial pour la biodiversité avec
23 cibles et une feuille de route
ambitieuse pour enrayer le déclin de la
biodiversité à l'échelle mondiale mais
il s'agit d'un accord qui est comme vous
le savez non contraignant donc son
succès repose Infiné sur la mise en
œuvre par chaque État des mesures
adéquates adapté à son cadre normatif et
à ses capacités budgétaires et à ses
ambitions donc dans ce domaine comme
dans d'autres la France peut jouer un
rôle moteur en la matière le crédit de
notre pays en matière de 10 diplomatie
climatique et environnementale est
important donc il faut travailler à le
maintenir donc selon quelle méthodologie
comptez-vous décliner les ambitions de
l'accord de kuming à Montréal dans la
stratégie nationale pour la biodiversité
2030 et quelles sont les mesures que
vous identifiez comme étant les plus
délicates à mettre en œuvre et une
intervention du législateur sera-t-elle
nécessaire
j'ai noté par ailleurs que dans le
programme 113 il porte désormais une
partie du financement de la SNB ça a été
rehaussé de 264 millions d'euros pour
2024 c'est une évolution qui mérite
d'être soulignée même si les efforts
pour réduire les pressions sur le vivant
comme vous l'avez indiqué réclament
certainement des moyens financiers
encore plus significatifs sans oublier
des moyens humains qui impliquent
nécessairement ce type de politique
publique certaines mesures ont déjà été
mis en œuvre notamment le la stratégie
des aires protégé d'autres impliquent un
étroit travail de concertation avec les
acteurs économique et financiers je
pense aussi au secteur agricole
notamment sur les réformes des
subventions néfastes à la biodiversité
ou à l'évaluation des impacts et des
dépendances des entreprises vis-à-vis de
la biodiversité quels sont les objectifs
que vous fixez en la matière et comment
associer efficacement la sphère privée
aux actions public en ce domaine tout en
ayant à l'esprit la compétitivité
nécessaire de nos entreprises à
préservver dans un
contexte international compliqué
j'aimerais également évoquer avec vous
la mise en œuvre des 53 mesures du plan
ha présenté en grande pompe si j'ose
dire en mars dernier par le Président de
la République avant de vous entendre
nous avons écouté nos collègues Remi
pointer et Hervé gilet qui ont mené les
travaux de la mission d'information sur
la gestion durable de l'eau ils se sont
attachés à proposer des des
recommandations à faire évoluer la la
gouvernance de la politique de l'eau et
améliorer la résilience hydrique de
notre pays dans le contexte de
changement climatique comptez-vous vous
inspirer de ces
travaux et naturellement sur le plan
haut je m'intéresse surtout au mesures
du plan haut qui n'ont pas été mises en
œuvre je pense à la tarification
incitative de l'eau à l'installation des
compteurs avec télétransmission ou
encore la définition d'objectifs
chiffrés de réduction des prélèvements
dans les sages et les PTG
comment vous expliquz les retards de
mise en œuvre d'autant que ce plan haut
fait suite aux assises de l'eau au
varèes agricole de l'eau au chantier
haut dans le cadre du CNR donc on était
en droit de penser que le cycle de
concertation qui associait tous les
acteurs avait pu lever les blocages
enfin ma dernière question porte sur le
la déclinaison du du fond vert en faveur
de la biodiversité on a relever que
l'enveloppe globale a été reéhaussée à
2,5 milliards d'euros avec des mesures
pour prévenir les inondations renaturer
les villes ou encore recycler les
friches donc pourriez-vous nous indiquer
si la mécanique de versement des crédits
issu de cette enveloppe évoluera ou
restera déconcentré au niveau des
préfets et par ailleurs quel bilan
faites-vous des actions qui ont
bénéficier de financement dans ce cadre
et de nouvelles priorités ont-elles été
identifié par votre ministère la
subsidiarité du versement des fonds
peut-elle encore être améliorée afin que
les élus locaux puissent bénéficier des
fonds avec un formalisme alléger on se
plaint en permanence et on veut une
débureaucratisation le fond vert
peut-être un bel outil à condition qu'il
soit simple d'accès pour toutes les
communes et notamment les plus petites
qui ont eu aussi elles aussi besoin de
d'un accompagnement donc à ce titre
pouvez-vous nous présenter la
ventilation des crédits du fond vert en
fonction de la typologie des territoires
et les réalisations les plus
emblématiques qui ont été porté dans le
cadre de la la première année d' mise en
œuvre du fond vert je vous
remercie merci euh madameam je vais vous
laisser répondre au rapporteur et puis
après je vais regouper les questions par
cinq
collègues avec plaisir monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
monsieur sénateur chevullier ce qui est
certain c'est que vous avez fait partie
effectivement du déplacement en
particulier qui a permis la signature
des accords de Cunningham Montréal et
quand j'ai pris dans l'ordre l'ensemble
des questions je pourrais je pourrais
répondre de manière très longue pendant
des heures mais je vais essayer d'aller
droite au but pour vous apporter un un
certain nombre de réponses les
orientations qui sont les presque les
plus claires et en même temps les plus
exigeantes c'est les 30 % d'air protégé
terre et M la réduction de 50 % des
espèces exotique envahissante des moyens
financiers il y en a pour le coup c'est
la pression est moins là puisque c'est
200 milliards par an toute source
confondu donc publi et privé et on est
dans une période où l'arrivée de la CSRD
plus de la tnfd qui a été présentée lors
du euh du climatrick euh la à New York
il a à peu près un mois donne en tout
cas pousse les fonds d'investissement et
les fonds souverains à financer plus
fortement les questions de biodiversité
donc des fonds peut-être plus que jamais
sont disponibles et vont dans vont
plutôt dans la bonne trajectoire ce qui
va être et ce qui est l'exercice
peut-être parce que vous avez demandé
qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur d'une
certaine manière mais qui est nécessaire
c'est aussi au-delà de spécialement
avoir de nouveau fonds c'est de baisser
un maximum aujourd'hui les subventions
néfastes et ça veut dire aussi
accompagner en profondeur des despans
entiers de notre de notre économie de
notre agriculture ce qui n'est pas
l'exercice le plus le plus simple
puisque vous avez pointé deux choses la
question des moyens financiers mais vous
avez aussi pointé la question de la non
distorsion de concurrence en particulier
sur le marché européen si je ne prenais
que cet exemple là et donc baisser ces
subventions néfastes qui sont euh qui
sont quand même si on prend au global
c'est plus de 10 milliards au niveau
européen 6 milliards exclusivement sur
la PAC de mémoire euh nous avons besoin
de travailler avec l'ensemble des
secteurs agricoles pour que cette
évolution soit une évolution européenne
et que ce soit pas exclusivement nos
territoire qui seraiit les premiers les
premiers
impactés mais ce qui ce qui est
nécessaire et ce qui est déjà ce qui est
déjà prévu si je prends dans l'ordre
vous m'avez demandé mais comment on fait
pour aller pour aller plus pour aller
plus loin pour aller plus loin il faut
aller atteindre les 10 % de protection
fortte nécessair dont qui sont inscrit
dans la stratégie nationale biodiversité
mais c'est 10 % de protection forte
c'est 5 % en mer 5 % sur les zones
terrestres ça veut dire
profondément des alliances nouvelles sur
les territoires permettant d'augmenter
la protection mais avec une vision
française qui est qui n'est pas la mise
sous cloche de nos territoires mais qui
est une coexistence une cohabitation en
tout cas une préservation qui conjugue
la présence humaine sur ces territoires
autant en mer que sur terre ça veut dire
aussi répondre à des enjeux qui ne sont
pas qui sont pas anodins de
développement de nos de nos territoires
tout en préservant et pour ça on a
besoin de de diagnostic et on a besoin
de moyens financiers et d'ingénierie
vous parliez de comment on pouvait mieux
accompagner les élus locaux pour accéder
au fond vert entre
autre il nous manque en tout cas il
manque encore aujourd'hui ce qui est
certain une brique ingénierie plus forte
nous y travaillons avec entre autres la
ministre en charge des collectivités et
Dominique fort pour voir comment on peut
mobiliser des moyens nouveaux en
ingénierie je pense à la NCT mais pas à
que permettant d'aller chercher
peut-être le je vais dire le dernier
kilomètre mais enfin pas loin euh pour
que les projets ne soient pas
exclusivement expertisés comme éligible
ou non éligible mais plutôt mieux
accompagné et donc de bénéficier euh du
fond vert et donc des moyens de
transformer euh de se transformer
jusqu'au bout euh la volonté qu'on voit
enfin moi je sincèrement quels que
soient les territoires ce que je vois
c'est beaucoup d'envie beaucoup de
mobilisation une prise de conscience qui
est quand même très accrue maintenant
c'est comment on y arrive comment on y
arrive en réussant à à à à conjuguer les
les contraintes vous avez également
parlé monsieur le monsieur le sénateur
de la question de l'eau et des 53
mesures évidemment la parlementaire que
je suis vous imaginez bien qu'elle
attend le de prendre connaissance du
rapport
de de de vos collègues avec beaucoup
d'intérêt pour voir comment on peut
aller je je je j'ai compris qu'il y
avait une en plus une symbolique forte
puisque ce rapport porte 53 propositions
donc moi je suis sensible au symboles je
je du coup je trouve voà j'ai hâte d'en
prendre connaissance et voir quels sont
les éléments qui peuvent aller aller
améliorer vous avez souligné la question
de la tarification incitative il y a des
communes qui l'ont qui l'ont qui la
mettent déjà en
œuvre pour le coup c'est des pas au
niveau de l'État d'aller ch en tout cas
moi j'aiama été une pro enfin j'is dire
obligation coerition la je suis plutôt
différenciation et mobilisation des
volontés des des collectivités et des
bassins des bassins aujourd'hui
l'incitation elle marche la tarification
incitative et progressive elle
fonctionne on prend le cadeau d'uncer où
je prends le cas de Monpellier que je
connais un peu plus c'est 10 % de
consommation en moin maintenant ça reste
ça reste des mesures à à pousser j'ai
demandé à mes services si la question du
compteur connecté qui est un vrai qui
est vraiment nécessaire enfin en terme
de prise de conscience mais aussi
d'évolution sur notre sobriété en
consommation pouvait être accompagné
financièrement j'ai pas encore tout à
fait le la réponse mais ce qui est
certain c'est que recevoir une facture
d'eau que à la fin de l'année ne permet
pas d'avoir un pilotage en tout cas
quand on est un particulier quotidien
cette prise de conscience et cette
mobilisation nécessite aussi la mise en
œuvre de ce qui a très bien marché
l'équivalent de l'écoat de l'eau qui a
très bien marché pendant cet hiver sur
la question de l'énergie c'est Vig c'est
un petit Pousset mais c'est un petit
pousser qui commence à s'installer dans
la vie quotidienne puisque ça s'appelle
Vig et depuis cet été je crois c'est de
je vous le fais aussi de mémoire mais
c'est 1 2 1,2 million de de visiteurs
uniques qui se sont connectés à nous
collectivement mais à mes services aussi
et bien de d'aller d'en faire la voilà
promotion peut-être un peu plus mais
c'est les premières briques qui nous
permettent une meilleure gestion
monsieur le Président j'essaie de faire
de des réponses synthétiques pour
permettre à l'ensemble des sénateurs et
sénatrices de commencer je j'essaie de
croiser le regard de monsieur le
rapporteur pour voir si ça la réponse
parfait merci donc je vais donner la
parole à Pascal Marta merci euh monsieur
le Président Madame la ministre mes
chers collègues ce matin c'est en
qualité d'ancien rapporteur de la loi
climat et résilience promulguée en août
2021 que je m'exprime
je suis naturellement comme mes
collègues particulièrement attaché à la
bonne application des dispositions de ce
texte les plus emblématiques mais
également celles qui ont moins fait
couler d'encre j'estime que le suivi de
cette loi d'ampleur inégalée est une
impérieuse nécessité après mettre
quelque peu investi pendant plusieurs
mois avec mes collègues philippe Tabarot
et Martha tidrac il faut aujourd'hui
assurer une veille
postlégislative s'intéresser au
déploiement de ces mesures dans le temps
tout en contrôlant la manière dont
l'état s'emploie à mettre en œuvre dans
et avec les territoires j'avais vous
l'avez évoqué madame la ministre
rapportter l'article relatif à la
stratégie nationale des airs protégées
si aujourd'hui et vous l'avez rappelé
l'objectif de mise sous protection de
moins 30 % du territoire national
terrestre et maritime est atteint nous
sommes malheureusement loin du compte
pour les aires sous protection forte
dont nous avions fixé la superficie de
façon exigeante mais nécessaire à 10 %
d'ici à 2030 il nous reste moins de 7
ans quand j'observe les les difficultés
les importants retards pour la création
d'un 12e parc national dédié aux zones
humides j'ai tout lieu d'être quelque
peu pessimiste madame la ministre
pourriez-vous nous éclairer sur ce point
en nous rassurant sur la trajectoire
fixée par votre ministère pour se
conformer aux objectifs fixés par le
législateur comment s'articule la
stratégie nationale des airs protégé
avec la stratégie en matière de lutte
contre l'artificialis des sols c'est
d'ailleurs un débat que le Sénat a
conduit avec sérieux et pragmatisme qui
a abouti à l'adoption de la loi visant à
faciliter la mise en œuvre des objectifs
d'zane au cœur des territoires quel
dialogue entretenez-vous avec les
territoires pour atteindre l'objectif de
décélération du rythme d'artificiisation
des sols j'enviens maintenant à
l'épineuse question de lauité écologique
avec son fameux article 19 bisc que
j'avais eu également à rapporter devenu
l'article 49 une fois la loi promulguée
ça fait référence au moulin dont les
débats ont été pour le moins
ouleux c'est un
euphémisme aujourd'hui le régime
juridique en matière d'aménagement de
seuil sur les cours d'eau est stabilisé
avec l'interdiction de la destruction
des ouvrages la stratégie nationale pour
la biodiversité envisaget-el de fixer de
nouveaux objectifs de restauration de
continuité écologique pouvez-vous nous
faire un bilan de la politique publique
en la matière enfin comment
décririez-vous les relations de
l'administration avec les propriétaires
de moulin à eut j'en viens et j'en
aurais terminé maintenant la question
centrale du financement de la
biodiversité vous l'avez évoqué dans
votre propos liminaire on ne résoudra
pas les manques de financement cent avec
seulement le lotau de la
biodiversité ni avec une dotation
budgétaire toujours insuffisante par
rapport aux enjeux quelles sont les
pistes que vous envisagez pour
diversifier les ressources quelle est
enfin la maturité des discussions ce
domaine notamment à Bery afin de
sécuriser des recettes fléché pour la
préservation de notre biodiversité je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
Stéphane deMille merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre nous avons
eu le le plaisir avec les les maires de
mie courours sur Somme étinant et et
d'Albert de vous accueillir dans dans la
Somme il y a il y a 2 jours pour
procéder au grattage d'un ticket de
l'auto mission nature chers collègues je
salue à titre personnel l'initiative de
de ce jeu destiné à à récolter
partiellement je l'entends bien des
fonds pour la défense de la biodiversité
nous le savons préserver la la
biodiversité n'est pas une lubie
écologique ce n'est pas le le reflet
d'une subite affection pour les animaux
et les végétaux c'est une nécessité afin
de préserver le socle sur lequel est
bâti notre monde notre société et notre
économie même toute notre économie
j'aimerais donc vous interroger
aujourd'hui spécifiquement sur la
question de la mobilisation des des
entreprises en faveur de la biodiversité
vous y avez fait allusion dans votre
introduction en parlant de l'implication
du monde industriel en effet pour
maintenir ces activités toute entreprise
dépend directement ou indirectement de
la biodiversité que ce soit pour
l'approvisionnement en matièrees
premières que soit pour la qualité de
l'eau que ce soit pour l'air ou encore
pour les services de régulation de plus
la Responsabilité Sociétale des
Entreprises la fameuse RSE incite les
entreprises nous le savons à réduire les
impacts de leurs activités sur
l'environnement et donc par définition
sur la biodiversité les entreprises
prennent de plus en plus conscience de
leur lien avec la biodiversité
souhaitent agir et mettre en place des
actions concrètes madame la ministre
comment les entreprises de notre
territoire de nos territoires
peuvent-elles concrètement et être mieux
soutenu dans la mise en œuvre des plans
d'action efficaces en faveur de la
biodiversité merci la parole est à
Gilbert Luc deinaz merci monsieur le
Président merci madame la ministre pour
votre éclairage j'avais deux petites
questions le président de la République
a proposé de planter un milliard
d'arbres dans la
décennie je je voulais poser la question
pourquoi un milliard d'arbres
euh quel type d'arbre quel type de
plantation et pour rejoindre une
question qu'a dû
poser Guillaume
chevrelier sachant que 75 % de la Florée
française est privée que un peu plus de
3 3 300000 sont propriétaires de cette
forêt comment vous allez mettre en place
des dispositifs pour encourager les
propriétaires à aller dans cet objectif
de planter un milliard d'arbres deuxième
petite question en terme de mobilité on
parle beaucoup de la production de
carbone par type de mobilité moi jerais
savoir s'il y a des études sur les
conséquences sur la biodiversité des
infrastruc structure de des mobilités
par type de mobilité et si quelque part
on peut savoir quel est le mode de
mobilité qui offre le meilleur rapport
entre production de gaz carbonique et
respect de la
biodiversité merci je vais donner la
parole à Cyril pelva merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre ma question
vous étonnera pas la stratégie nationale
de biodiversité 2030 a notamment pour
objectif de réduire les pressions sur la
biodiversité ainsi que de protéger et
restaurer les écosystèmes de fait la
préservation d'espèces sauvages tes que
Lou s'inscrit pleinement dans cette
stratégie même si à l'occasion d'un
rapport en 2018 j'avais démontré qu'il y
avait un recul pour la biodiversité avec
une une arrivée massive du loup d'OM
massif Alpa or depuis plusieurs années
la population lupine connaît une
croissance exponentielle le nombre de
loups en France a doublé entre 2018 et
2023 passant selon les chiffres à 1104
spécimenses si la classification du loup
comme espèce strictement protégé a
permis la préservation et même le
développement de l'espèce elle a
également de terribles conséquences sur
le pastoralisme à la hausse du nombre
d'individus s'accompagne inévitablement
le nombre d'animaux tués par les élevag
dans les élevages français ce sont en
tout 58000 animaux qui ont été tués par
le loup depuis 2018 au-delà de
constituer un coût de 19,5 million
d'euros d'indemnité pour l'État ces
attaques de plus en plus nombreuses et
régulières menacent directement la
pérenité de l'élevage de l'élevage
français dernièrement le gouvernement a
présenté le nouveau plan loup pour la
période 24-29 des mesures de limitation
de la prote loup sont ont été exposé
parmi celles-ci le gouvernement visage
de demander un réexamen du statut du
loup d'espèces strictement protégé
espèces protégé afin de permettre de
mieux le réguler aussi je souhaiterais
savoir si cette demande de réexamen a
déjà été déposée par le gouvernement et
si vous l'avez et si vous avez déjà eu à
connaître le positionnement de la
Commission européenne au sujet de cette
modification sachant qu'à l'occasion
d'une proposition de résolution
européenne qui avait été déposé par ma
collègue Sylvian Noël et dont j'avais
été rapporteur nous avions eu une fin de
non recevoir voilà je vous remercie
euh je vais donner la parole à Nicole
Bonnefois merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre bonjour ma question
moi portera sur les espèces exotiques
envahissantes et plus particulièrement
le frelon asiatique qui met à rude
épreuve nos apiculteurs dans mon
département la semaine dernière un
apiculteur c'était 14 ruches sur 17
qu'il qu'il avait perdu et bien
évidemment le réchauffement climatique
offre des conditions optimales au
développement de de ces colonies
maintenant jusqu'à l'automne donc aucun
territoire n'est épargné il y a quelques
années j'étais intervenu sur le sujet on
était au au début de de de la
prolifération maintenant tout le monde
est est est est concerné les
collectivités ben essaient de faire ce
qu'elles peuvent mais en luttant avec
leurs moyens le problème c'est que la
lutte n'est pas coordonnée vous le savez
donc les les le le il y a pas de les
actions donc sont vaines vous évoquez
dans l'axe 8 de votre stratégie 500
opérations coû de point d'ici à 2025
visant ainsi une réduction de moitié du
taux d'établissement de ces espèces
invasives pour 2030 vous indiquer
vouloir mobiliser les collectivités et
les acteurs sur des endroits
sensibles néanmoins la fiche 10
mentionne que les espèces visées par ce
programme concernera surtout celle en
cours d'installation notamment en
outreem donc mes questions sont les
suivantes qu'attendez-vous
qu'entendez-vous pardon par opération
coup de point le frollon asiatique
fera-t-il partie des espèces concerné
par ces opérations comment
identifierez-vous les endroits sensibles
et quels moyen financier votre ministère
entend apporter à cette politique
évidemment les apiculteurs de mon
département mais les apiculteurs de la
France entière attendent des réponses
forte pour réguler le le frolon aciaci
qui ravage les ruches mais qui met bien
évidemment également en danger notre
biodiversité à terme la pollinisation
donc merci pour votre réponse
je vais donner la parole à Simon
usona merci monsieur le Président Madame
la la ministre deux sujets l'eau et
l'agriculture sur l'eau nous en avons
parlé juste avant votre audition en
particulier sur la
réutilisation des eaux usé traité vous
avez signé un décret le 29 août dernier
il y a un enjeu pour nous très important
en Bretagne avec la place très forte des
industries agroalimentaires de pouvoir
effectivement les mobiliser elles sont
plutôt très volontaires alors il
semblerait qu'un certain nombre de Tex
soit à venir sur le sujet est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus pour
effectivement les mobiliser au-delà des
1000 projets évoqué d'ici 2027 parce
qu'il faudra sans doute là aussi aller
plus loin deuxième sujet sur
l'agriculture en l'occurrence parmi les
priorités identifiées dans la stratégie
nationale dont vous nous avez présenté
la la synthèse
figure la transition agroécologique et à
ce titre il existe un outil important
les mesures agro-environnementale et et
climatique de seconde génération alors
il se trouve que c'est un regret
évidemment la France est l'État membre
de l'Union européenne qui all loue la
plus faible part du second pilier de la
politique agricole commune au MAEC donc
ça c'est c'est déjà un premier regret
mais
surtout le l'État n'est pas au
rendez-vous au plan financier ça était
déjà évoqué en particulier avec région
de France à l'occasion du congrès qui
s'est tenu à Saint-Malo mais il manque
300 millions d'euros au niveau nationale
pour la région Bretagne c'est 53
millions d'euros pour
3000 exploitations des agriculteurs qui
se sont engagés et pour lesquels la
promesse d'un financement de fait assuré
par l'État pourrait ne pas être au
rendez-vous donc nous avons joué le jeu
les élus les acteurs économiques au sens
large pour pour accélérer cette
transition agroécologique il ne serait
pas compréhensible que l'État ne soit
pas au rendez-vous donc plusieurs
démarches ont été conduites auprès de de
différents ministres en particulier le
ministre de l'Agriculture est-ce que
vous pourriez nous apporter des garanti
sur ce point et puis terminer enfin
toujours sur le sujet agricole sur la
partie agriculture biologique vous fixez
l'objectif de 20 % de surface agricole
utile à horizon 2030 c'est inférieur à
l'objectif européen euh est-ce que vous
comptez
réévaluer cette ambition et puis enfin
sur le respect de la loi égalim là aussi
l'état n'est pas au rendez-vous bien en
dessà de ce que les collectivités
locales sont dors et déjà en capacité de
faire en particulier sur les 50 % de
produits sous signes de qualité servis
dans la restauration collective et les
20 % issu de l'agriculture bio est-il
prévu une mobilisation supplémentaire de
l'État pour être là aussi au rendez-vous
des attentes je vous
remercie je vais donner la la parole à
Sébastien
Fagen merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues la
question du recul du trait de côte
occupe de nombreux esprits parmi les
1000 communes littorales françaises près
de la moitié d'entre elles sont
directement concerné un horizon
particulièrement proche euh on témoigne
d'ailleurs la la présence de monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique au
dernier congrès de de la nelle où la
question du financement a été
abondamment évoqué et débattu un rapport
lui sera remis d'ici quelques semaines
pour pouvoir accompagner euh autant que
possible et du mieux que possible les
collectivités face cette tâche d'ampleur
pour ne pas dire titanesque si
l'essentiel de nos efforts aujourd'hui
se concentrre sur la question de la
relocalisation des biens euh ce qui est
une évidence euh au regard euh de la
sensibilité particulière de ces
opérations foncière mais aussi humaine
puisque l'on touche à l'habitat la
question du traitement des espaces
renaturés et qui ont été pendant des
décennies façonné par la main de l'homme
se pose également madame la ministre un
axe de travail et de réflexion est-il
prévu au sein de la Stratégie nationale
pour la biodiversité sur la restauration
et l'accompagnement des collectivités de
ces espaces afin qu'ils redeviennent des
espaces dédiés à la continuité
écologique je vous remercie merci chers
collègues je donne la parole à Martha de
Sidrac merci président madame la
ministre vous avez évoqué dans vos
propos liminires les principales mesur
de la stratégie nationale de la
biodiversité je voudrais revenir plus
spécifiquement sur l'une des mesures
donc qui apparaissent et que vous avez
effectivement évoqué aussi dans vos
propos liminires c'est celle qui
concerne le renforcement de la lutte
contre la pollution plastique et
notamment dans la mesure il est question
de résorber 94 décharges littoral en
fait portant sur ce sujet-là donc moi
j'avais une question une première
question là-dessus comment comptez-vous
de façon très opérationnel et donc le
sujet de l'efficacité me semble
important vous y prendre pour pouvoir
les résorber d'autant plus que j'ai
étéaré de au détour de ma de la presse
quotidienne de voir que il y a encore
des communes certes pas littorales je
pense à une commune qui déversait depuis
plus de 10 ans ses déchets dans le
fleuve Levard euh sans pour pour autant
que cela n'est suscité jusque-l une
quelconque interrogation et d'ailleurs
ce sont les agents de l'ofb qui ont
découvert au détour d'un passage tout à
fait impromptu voilà que cela se passait
donc depuis un certain nombre d'années
ma deuxième question madame la ministre
sans vouloir abuser de votre temps vous
vous êtes réjoui et je pense que nous
sommes un certain nombre également
contents de cela c'est que le budget
évidemment est augmenté vous l'avez
rappelé moi je pose la question
simplement là encore de l'efficacité
pour faire quoi comment comptez-vous
nous assurer que l'efficacité sera au
rendez-vous sur tous ces sujets-là je
pense notamment à l'accompagnement de
nos communes vous avez également évoqué
le fond vert et le manque je reprends
votre expression du manque du dernier
kilomètre peut-être vous avez aussi
évoqué la NCT qui est censé accompagner
nos communes moi je viens d'un
département les Yvelines où la NCT est
pour ainsi dire absente puisque le
artement la région sont véritablement
les réels accompagnateurs de nos
communes donc c'est bien il y a je sens
une forme de volonté de votre part
toutefois je souhaite m'assurer
véritablement que les fonds seront bien
utilisé efficace au au bénéfice de nos
communes parce que le fond vert on a
déjà d on a déjà des cils et quand il
faut se battre pour pouvoir accompagner
nos communes dans les territoires ce
n'est pas tout toujours évident de
connaître précisément quels sont les
bons critères donc je voulais avoir des
réponses à ces sujets je vous
remercie si je vais donner la parole à
Jean-Claude danglar merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre vous le
savez la préservation de la biodiversité
passe également par une agriculture
préservée et forte notamment en zone de
montagne alors je le dis parce que ma
question était sur le loup mais mon
collègue Cyril PEV l'a posé et donc on
vous a lu dans le monde n'est-ce pas du
19 septembre vous avez dit la hausse de
la population justifie qu'on lâche un
peu de l'ISS sur la procédure et qu'on
soit plus efficace sur les tirs donc ça
nous a beaucoup intéressé vous nous
direz comment depuis vous avez avancé
sur le sujet et ma deuxième question
porte sur un autre animal qui s'appelle
le ratopied je sais pas si vous savez ce
qui'est le rat auied en tout cas votre
prédécesseur ne connaissait pas qui SVIT
essentiellement dans le Massif Central
donc c'est un campagnol trestre n'est-ce
pas qui qui menace vraiment les prairies
les prairies les prairies naturelles qui
s'attaqueent aux racines et détruisent
l'herbe nécessaire à l'élevage et donc
c'est un fléo c'est un fléo et donc on a
interrogé plusieurs fois le ministère
sur ce sujet donc je voulais avoir votre
avis sur la question du rat au piied
dans le Massif Central notamment
merci merci et pour cette première série
de questions je vais donner la parole à
notre collègue Fabien
Jeunet merci monsieur le Président d'un
d'un fléo à l'autre je reviens sur euh
le loup et la question qu'a posé Cyril
pelva pour à la fois appuyer et
compléter son son intervention et ce qui
me permettra de rebondir également
appuyer pour dire combien effectivement
cette pression du loup est de plus en
plus prignante ça a été dit en 2018 38
départements concernés aujourd'hui 53
dont la sonelloir qui est un des
nouveaux fronts de colonisation du du
loup avec des attaques qui se
multiplient qui concernent désormais à
la fois des robis des agneaux des
béliers mais aussi des broutards donc il
y a une évolution vers des attaques sur
les bovins et encore il y a quelques
jours 13 pauvres brebis qui ont été
obligés de se jeter à la rivière dans la
Grône pour échapper au au prédateurs et
je ne vous redis pas Madame la Ministre
combien au-delà des attaques sur les
animaux et les questions que cela nous
pose puisque nous sommes tous de plus en
plus sensibilisés sur le bien-être
animal lorsqu'on voit les dégâts
provoqués par le loup
les animaux
massacrés et bien effectivement on se
pose un certain nombre de questions sur
le sujet et je rappelle également les
perturbations terribles que cela cause
aux éleveurs qui effectivement vivent
désormais dans l'angoisse de ces
attaques et qui vivent très très mal
psychologiquement ces attaques contre
leurs animaux et la mise en cause de de
leur travail compléter peut-être la
question effectivement je fais mienne
l'interrogation de de Cyril sur votre
position sur le changement de statut de
de l'espèce mais au-delà de cette
question peut-être vous demandez et
également du calendrier sur lequel on
aimerait avoir des précisions très très
claires peut-être également quelques
précisions sur votre position concernant
les autres aspects les problèmes de
comptage de l'espèce au niveau national
au niveau européen la problématique des
tirs de prélèvement mais également tout
ce qui tourne autour des moyens de
protection puisque vous savez qu'il y a
beaucoup d'interrogation des éleveurs
sur les chiens pasatou et sur le statut
de ce chien donc est-ce que là-dessus
vous avez également des annonces à nous
faire et pour ne pas être trop long je
voudrais également mentionner qu'en sonn
etloire ce problème du loup nous nous
amène à vous demander de prendre en
compte les spécificités du territoire
bocagé des plaines et du bocage qui rend
très
difficile les mesures de protection et
et ça m'amène effectivement à rebondir
sur ce que vous disiez dans votre propos
liminire sur la beauté des paysages le
caractère immatériel de de ceci à
appeler votre attention sur le fait
qu'en sonelloir également nous sommes
très en pointe là-dessus ça correspond à
une des actions de votre stratégie
nationale de biodiversité en particulier
sur la protection des hais et je ne sais
pas si vous savez que le charolet
Brionnais souhaite classer le paysage de
l'élevage bovin charoletis au patrimoine
mondial de
UNESCO avec une inscription sur la liste
des biens de l'État français la valeur
universelle exceptionnelle de de ce bien
a déjà été reconnu nous sommes dans la
dernière ligne droite et naturellement
avec l'ensemble des élus du département
nous serions très heureux de pouvoir
vous compter à nos côtés pour défendre
cette très belle candidature je vous
remercie madame les ministre je vous
donne la parole pour répondre à ces
quelques
questions
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président on m'avait dit que la la
commission était exigeante je je
confirme la la réputation d'exigence
et des des questions donc je vais
essayer de j'ai pris des notes essayer
de répondre à l'ensemble en tout cas au
maximum des interrogations pour
commencer monsieur le député Pascal
Martin vous avez monsieur le
sénateur
sénateur j'ai pens àeses propre à mes
propres collègues mais monsieur le
sénateur
excusez-moi vous avez particulièrement
posé la question peut-être avant de
rentrer dans la question de la
protection de comment on l'a fait vous
avez posé la question du du 12e parc
national je pense que le temps que ça
prend la difficulté que ça ça amène à le
mettre en œuvre c'est l'illustration
aujourd'hui d'une peut-être d'une
incompréhension très profonde sur
qu'est-ce que signifie une protection
jusqu'où ça va et finalement quels sont
est-ce que il y a une perte de pouvoir
local est-ce que est-ce que c'est que
des contraintes ou pas pas et c'est
comme ça que c'est perçu encore beaucoup
trop ce qui est certain c'est que le
dernier rapport de de de l'inspection
que nous avons reçu reçu ciblé trois
territoire en tout cas qui serait dans
un idéal la Camargue la Loire et la
guuyane ce qui est certain c'est que il
n'y a pas de territoire qui se dégage de
manière volontaire en tout cas on n pas
encore de territoirees qui disent bah
moi je suis prêt à soutenir ou
accueillir un parc national mais ce qui
est certain c'est que je pense que nous
aujourd'hui nous avons une opportunité
en or pour faire que ce ce ce parc
national qui est dans la stratégie
nationale biodiversité soit une chance
pour le territoire qui va l'accueillir
et c'est une réelle chance pour plein de
raisons d'abord parce que c'est des
moyens supplémentaires des moyens
financiers supplémentaires de
rayonnement on parler de valeur
paysageère on parlait de valeur en de de
de de préservation d'espèces mais aussi
de moyens nouveaux les parcs le
permettent et la question qui se pose
c'est comment nous faisons le pas
peut-être de de de zones déjà qui sont
protégées à des protections plus plus
fort à des cœurs de parc mais c'est un
changement de de en profondeur dans la
manière de faire et la manière d'
d'accompagner d'installer ce parc
national plus spécifiquement mais je
suis confiante sur les prochaines sur
les prochaines semaine concernant la
stratégie plus large de protection
effectivement nous avons aujourd'hui une
marche qui est quand même ambitieuse on
passe de 1,2 % à un objectif de 10 %
pour y arriver pour y arriver euh on a
absolument besoin de d'avoir en tout cas
un portage moitié mer moitié moitié
terre 100 % des récifs coralien c'est
c'est quand même c'est quand même la
l'objectif 100 % des herbiers de
posidonie pour le sud de la de la France
et je pense à la Méditerranée en
particulier qui qui ont vocation à être
en zone de protection forte mais enfin
le
plus le la réussite dépendra de la
qualité de la la relation avec les aus
locaux pour être très très clair et et
très explicite euh concernant vous avez
aussi souligné un point qui était
important qui était la continuité
écologique et la question des moulins
vous savez monsieur monsieur le sénateur
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
c'est comment on accompagne un maximum
ces continuité écologique la la Haute
Assemblée s'est exprimée sur les moulins
se pose la question de comment on
accompagne les
seuils la propriété privée et
aujourd'hui inscrite dans nos textes les
plus importants cependant on a besoin
d'accompagner ces ces continuités avec
l'accord avec le travail de concertation
et le dialogue au plus au plus au niveau
le plus proche faisons la distinction
entre les seuils et les moulins aussi un
certain moment et appuyons-nous sur tous
les moyens qui permettent évidemment je
pense au passe à poisson mais pas que
puisqu'on sait à quel point les passes à
poisson c'est c'est un cout énorme et en
même temps c'est un bout de la réponse
mais elle est pas elle est pas exclusive
elle est pas elle est pas parfaite euh
vous avez également souligné la question
de la diversification des ressources
évidemment il y a un budget loi de finan
qui est soclé donc qui est plutôt qui
qui est plutôt bon signe une
augmentation très large du budget de du
ministère et du pôle avec les 10
milliards donc on s'inscrit dans ça mais
enfin si on est si on va au bout de la
démarche il faut des moyens nouveaux
d'accord il y en a pour qu'il y en ait
un peu plus il faut des moyens nouveaux
du monde privé il faut baisser les
subventions néfastes également parce
qu'en fait ENF il faut pas soit un pu
des danaïdesin sinon ça on a
l'impression que ça ça n'ira pas en tout
cas suffisamment et puis enfin il y a
aussi besoin je pense d'une
diversification des ressources au sens
comment on crée un crédit biodiversité
et c'est la mission qui est aujourd'hui
donnée par la par le Président de la
République à Sylvie Gour
Sylvie Gour par Gouro non bon avec nos
homologues allemands avec nos homologues
britanniques pour vous pour créer des
crédit des crédits biodiversité et donc
plus largement lev des fonds
Goulard Gouard c'est je je pensais à
Jacqueline gourau qui était également
votre collègue mais du coup je c'est
c'est pas exactement le c'est pas les
mêmes les mêmes sujets de de
prédilection et et enfin puisque vous
avez ça a été un trait d'union entre
l'intervention du sénateur Martin et du
sénateur demi sur l' tau de la
biodiversité peut-être pour éclaircir le
sujet c'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga du
financement de la biodiversité très
clair moi je me souviens très bien de la
position de cette de la de la de cette
assemblée concernant cette idée les
questions d'addiction ont été travaillé
pour faire hyper attention on ne sait
rien d'autre qu'appuyer sur ce qu' a
réussi à faire le loto du patrimoine en
terme de de mobilisation aujourd'hui ces
6 millions d'euros c'est pas une
trajectoire budgétaire enfin fa être
très clair pas du tout c'est 1 milliard
de l'objectif budgétaire ce qui est
certain par contre c'est une c'est une
mobilisation une information majeur en
flashant le code et donc c'est plutôt
une dans la stratégie de mobilisation
plus que de budgétaire en tout cas je
souhaitais quand même le souligner
j'aimerais pas laisser imaginer que la
biodiversité est portée par le loto ce
qui serait franchement extrêmement
partiel non non pas du tout non non mais
je répond plus largement pas du tout
monsieur le sénateur mais c'est pour
c'est éclaircir un certain nombre de
sujets concernant monsieur le
sénateur demi vous avez dit comment du
coup au-delà du loto et de la visite des
de la tourbière qui sur votre territoire
bénéficie de ce de ce projet avec plus
de 800000 € de mémoire sur un projet de
préservation vous avez parlé de la
mobilisation des entreprises et comment
on fait ce qui est certain c'est que on
a la CSRD qui arrive et c'est une
directive européenne qui a vocation à
être transposée avant la fin de l'année
par la France il faut être extrêmement
vigilant pour qu'elle soit
opérationnelle dès l'année prochaine
puisque ça touche les entreprises de
plus de 500 salariés et dans la foulée
les plus de 250 l'année qui suit qui
certain c'est que quand on touche des
entreprises de plus de 500 en réalité
toute la chaîne de production et la
chaîne de valeur donc les sous-traitants
sont touchés et pour y arriver et bien
nous travaillons d'ors et déjà avec un
certain nombre de filières pour
faciliter sa sa mise en œuvre
concrètement ça veut dire quoi dire que
les entreprises vont avoir des
obligation de déclaration
extrafinancière permettant de de mettre
un point sur leur dépendance à la
question en tout cas des
écosystème naturel aujourd'hui on a
encore un retard de connaissance c'est
c'est une titude mais il faut pas
oublier nos plus petites entreprises nos
artisans et donc il y a aujourd'hui un
projet qui est porté par je vous le fais
de mémoire par laadem
et par l'ADEM et la banque des
territoires pour accompagner un outil
qui sera plus accessible pour les TPE et
PME et qui soient eux-mêmes d'une
certaine manière en capacité bah de
s'autodiagnostiquer et du coup de
baisser leur dépendance il y a pas un
modèle économique où on garde une
variable inconnue c'est en tout cas
c'est c'est un essentiel et puis la
Banque de France dans le cadre du réseau
des Banques centrales qui se mobilise
avec les premières hypothèses qui seront
publiées en novembre
concernant quel quel risque de stress
test sur notre économie et sur nos
secteurs sachant que le plus impacté
sera certainement la construction et
l'alimentation qui ont les plus grandes
dépendances la question de l'eau étant
primordiale dans cette dépendance m
monsieur le député euh monsieur le
sénateur monsieur sénateur de vines
c'est c'est c'est inquiétant parce qu'en
fait je me sens bien dans la commission
monsieur le Président et donc du coup
j'ai l'impression d'être d'être en
commission monsieur le sénateur euh vous
avez parlé du milliard d'arbres pourquoi
pourquoi un milliard à planter euh et le
fait que 75 % de notre forêt est privé
vous avez raison les travaux sur le
projet d'un milliard d'arbres en réalité
s'appuient évidemment sur la
mobilisation des propriétaires fonciers
privés puisque c'est les plus c'est les
premiers propriétaires de la de la forêt
française mais pourquoi un milliard
parce qu'en moyenne en France on plante
entre 50 et 60 millions d'arbres et donc
l'effort c'est de le doubler si on passe
de 50 millions d'arbres plantés à 100
millions c'est un effort de
renouvellement de génération au moment
où la forêt française subit bah déjà des
attaques de scolite assez fort mais
aussi des morts subites lié en réalité
au dérèglement climatiqu qui fait que
nos essences pour une partie d'entre
elles n'arrivent pas à s'adapter à la
vitesse du dérèglement nous avons
vocation effectivement dans ce dans
cette ambition d'accompagner certain
nombre de propriétaires qui le
souhaitent peut-être le plus difficile
mais c'est une réalité de notre de notre
pays c'est le morcellement de la forêt
de la de la forêt privée et c'est les
petits propriétaires qui pour un certain
nombre ne sont propriétaires parce que
c'est une c'est un héritage et
aujourd'hui n'ont pas encore conscience
parfois de de leur propre propriété ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il faut
accompagner la préservation de nos
forêts pour garantir sa qualité et donc
quelles essences le les la question des
essences on la travaille avec l'ONF
principalement et un certain nombre de
chercheurs pour voir remonter des
essences du Sud vers vers le centre et
puis du centre vers le nord mais ça
c'est le pur produit de la du
dérèglement climatique vous avez posé la
question également du carbone et des
mobilités en
disant comment comment on pose on pose
le sujet dans le cadre de la
présentation de la planification
écologique effectivement les mobilités
génèent un certain nombre de de
d'émission on choisit de pas opposer
décarbonation et biodive c'est en fait
c'est les c'est le même enfin en tout
cas c'est les deux faces d'un combat
qu'on pourrait appeler jumeau et donc la
question des infrastructures aujourd'hui
qui sont prises dans la dans le cadre de
la Stratégie nationale biodiversité
c'est plutôt la
résorption des difficultés de continuité
de continuité écologique sur l'ensemble
du territoire et d'accompagner plutôt le
ministre des Transports dans
l'électricification de la flotte ou
encore le développement de transport de
transport en commun moins
énergivore monsieur le sénateur pelva
vous avez posé la question du loup et en
fait vous avez posé deux questions en
réalité la question du statut du loup et
du du PNA et du coup du retour sur le
PNA la question du statut à ma
connaissance au moment où on se parle il
n'y a pas eu de demandes qui ont été
réactivé suite aux déclarations de la
présidente
vonlen en tout cas un calendrier plus
clair par contre si on rentre dans notre
calendrier national à nous il se trouve
que le la préfette coordinatrice a
présenté le plan le plan lou aux acteurs
il y a quelques semaines maintenant et
que nous allons ouvrir dans les
prochains jours la consultation publique
sur sur ce plan
lou ça reste aujourd'hui une espèce
strictement protégée ce qui est certain
c'est que la dynamique elle est réelle
la question de la viabilité
démographique et plutôt acté sur notre
territoire la viabilité génétique ne
l'est pas encore et donc la question de
la viabilité génétique devra être non
mais devrait être levé compté avec nos
voisins italiens enfin principalement
sur l'arc alpin je aujourd'hui au moment
où je vous parle je ne sais pas vous
dire si c'est atteint pas atteint je ne
saais pas vous le dire je ne présage pas
de la réponse d'ailleurs mais ce qui est
certain c'est que nous avons pas à la
porter seul nous avons à l'apporter avec
nos avec nos nos voisins
frontaliers il faut pas laisser imaginer
parce que je l'ai entendu de la part
d'un certain nombre enin dans dans le
débat public que si le statut du loup
venait à changer pour des raisons voilà
de d'évolution et de démographie ou de
viabilité atteinte qui n'aurait plus
aucune protection même s'il venait à
passer de très strictement à protéger en
réalité il reste des modalités de
protection et je pense que c'est
important de de le rappeler
la le plan national qui a été présenté
est un plan équilibré ce qui me permet
aussi de répondre à à d'autres d'autres
sujets sur la mais je reviendrai sur les
modalités de tir plus spécifiquement
puisque la question m'a été
posée et donc le calendrier européen
pour le moment pas de mais l'arrivée des
séances électorales peut présager que
peut-être ça pourrait s'accélérer mais
pas plus de en tout cas d'information
sur ce point madame la sénatrice bonne
foi sur les sur les espèces exotiques
envahissante aujourd'hui le fron
asiatique effectivement fait fait des
dégâts absol
absolument partout ce qui ce qui est
certain c'est que nous avons un plan un
plan d'action et budgétaire pour le coup
plus que plus que renforcé ouais pour
répondre à un certain nombre de de
conséquences et d'enjeux et pour vous
rassurer le frelon asiatique est bien
dans les priorités qui sont qui sont
porté aujourd'hui de mémoire on a on
attend le retour de de l'inspection d'un
rapport d'inspection permettant de
mobiliser plus de manière plus
opérationnelle les 500 missions coup de
point en fait comment on les comment on
les met en œuvre et on le fait avec les
collectivités territoriales même si
c'est pas le sujet de votre question sur
vous avez parlé du frelon asiatique on a
eu cet été aussi beaucoup de de communes
qui ont été en difficulté face au Mousti
tigre et donc nous travaillons avec la
ministre firmain lebudau qui a eu des
conséquences enfin sur la santé du coup
des habitants et là l'objectif c'est de
coordonner les travaux avec nos deux
ministères et que ces cou c'est coup de
point soit bien porté sur les
territoires avec les élus qui sont du
coup en première
ligne
et et les moyens financiers juste pour
vous donner la ligne budgétaire parce
que je pense que c'est important pour
les élus que vous accompagnez au
quotidien c'est 800 c'est plus de 800000
€ supplémentaires pour financer Vial de
Real qui seront ouais Vial realal tout à
fait sur les territoires et si vous
souhaitez plus d'informations sur sur
votre territoire je peux demander à mes
services de se mobiliser avec avec
plaisir euh monsieur le sénateur
na euh sur la question de la c'estna
NA pardon usena sur les prochains
décrets parce que vous m'avez parlé de
l'eau et de la question de la réut un
premier décret a été effectivement rendu
public principalement sur les questions
de voirie he enfin si si on devait
schématiser aujourd'hui on a l'objectif
de 1000 projets de rut dans la stratégie
nationale biodiversité on est à peine à
1 % d'utilisation les deux prochain il y
a deux décrets qui arrivent vous avez
raison le prochain il est sur
l'utilisation pour
l'agroalimentaire qui permettra en
réalité d'utiliser dans le monde
industriel plus d'eau en circuit en
circuit fermé et qui permettra aussi
d'accompagner le projet de sobriété et
l'objectif de 10 % de consommation en
moins puisque la question c'est comment
on augmente
euh la des eaux disponibles sans que ce
soit de l'eau potable au premier au
premier abord et le deuxième c'est
comment on baisse nos consommations nos
consommations d'eau et puis le dernier
décret qui est plutôt attendu vers
décembre celui-là c'est sur les usages
domestiques et qui permettra bien sûr à
un certain nombre de paires et puis
surtout de collectivité de voir par
exemple de l'eau je pense de l'eau de
pluie dans dans les sanitaires enfin
c'est juste un un exemple parmi d'autres
vous avez également posé pas mal de
questions monsieur le sénateur sur les
la question agricole et la question de
la de la transition agroécologique alors
il y aura un pan un peu plus musclé sur
la transition agroécologique dans la
stratégie nationale biodiversité mais
qui est encore un des points qui est
en peut mieux faire si vous me permettez
l'expression et sur lequel nous
travaillons avant de rendre cette
stratégie
nationale publique et ensuite sur les
questions de la du positionnement de la
France sur le 2uxème pilier mais aussi
les questions des 300 millions qui
seraient un manque au niveau national
pour le coup je n'ai pas cette
information là et je vous propose de
revenir dessus puisque je crois que
c'est en j'ai la certitude que c'est en
coordination avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture et donc je me rapprocherai
pour le coup de lui pour vous apporter
la la réponse dans les plus brefs délais
euh monsieur le sénateur Fagan on a vous
m'avez sollicité sur la question du
recul du trait de côte et du financement
aujourd'hui principalement où on on
relocalise les biens il y a deux enjeux
et en fait ça a été ça a été souligné
également par par votre collègue le
risque de submersion aussi pose deux
questions d'abord nous travaillons très
bien avec le président Moro il se trouve
que c'est un voisin de territoire
également avec sa casquette de mer mais
là c'est plutôt sa casquette de
président de la de des villes et des
communes littorales l'accompagnement est
porté en plus au niveau du ministre de
l'écologie par Christophe Béchu lui-même
sur comment on accompagne l'évolution
mais moi ma vigilance est ce qui qui
sera très fort dans la stratégie
nationale biodiversité c'est comment on
évite la submersion de décharges qui
sont aujourd'hui et qui vont être pour
nous une priorité parce que la
submersion aujourd'hui on pense à la
relocalisation effecidemment des biens
enfin si on arrive dans une situation où
la où la où le trait de côte recule et
que la submersion nous amène à avoir des
pollutions territoriales ce serait pour
le coup dramatique donc la ce qu' sur
lequel le point sur lequel on focuse le
plus euh c'est celui-là madame la
sénatrice Sidrac euh vous avez également
parlé madame la sénatrice de cette
question de de pollution aussi et de
pollution pour le coup qu'on a parfois
pas identifié moi j'ai été
particulièrement touché mais ça vient un
peu compléter vos propos sur le fait
d'avoir identifié des lieux mais
quasiment par hasard ce qui est
malheureux la réalité est là d'où d'où
l'opportunité que j'ai aujourd'hui de
saluer le travail de l'ofb même si
aujourd'hui je sais que leur mission a
aussi vocation à être euh voilà mieux
connu mieux accompagné plus en
adéquation avec nos élus locaux pour
avoir voilà plus d'impact en tout cas
euh sur sur en terme
d'efficacité quand on a eu les les les
incendies en Bretagne euh à la après on
a identifié je crois c'était 2,5 tonnes
de déchets dans la dans les forêts du
mondarrê qu'on avait pas sous les yeux
de fait mais qui était bien là et donc
la question aujourd'hui des pollutions
et de la manière de les résorber et
absolument absolument
nécessaire et donc l'accompagnement
évidemment va de va de so madame la
sénatrice
euh monsieur le
sénateur sur euh les les
ratopied je suis obligée de vous dire
que je non je je je ne connais pas en
toute sincérité les ratopied mais que
effectivement euh pour le coup mes
services maîtrisent local ah je oui je
je l'avoue je je l'avoue je l'avoue
simplement ce qui est certain c'est que
effectivement euh les est de ce que de
ce qu'on dit favorise ses prédateurs et
donc faut être vigilant dans le cadre de
l'élevage qui vit lui-même une pression
une pression
particulière mais les solutions sur la
nature qui le permettent c'est plutôt
favoriser effectivement des rapaces
prédateurs qui permettrait de lutter
contre ces rates au piieds mais au-delà
monsieur le sénateur de manière très ser
de la question des rapaces qui pourrait
permettre de lutter contre les ratopi je
n'ai pas une expertise qui pourrait
éclairer les travaux de de la commission
vous avez également posé la question des
modalités de tir sur lequel je peux
revenir peut-être plus plus en détail
les modalités de tir elles ont été
travaillées avec les louftiers elles ont
été également dans le S pas levé on
reste on reste il n'y a pas de tir s'il
n'y a pas d'attaque enfin je pense qu'il
faut rappeler le la la philosophie
cependant il y avait aujourd'hui parce
que la dynamique est
positive nécessité d'accompagner plus
les modalités permettant au louftier
d'être équipé parce que je pense que
dans le dans le plan où les équipes
d'ailleurs de de lunettes nocturnes on a
fait évoluer la modalité de la lumière
parce qu'il fallait marquer la lumière
avant de de tirer mais on reste sur une
réponse de défense à postériori puis il
y avait les les les groupes qui
pouvaient tirer parce que c'était la
question des des tirs des tirs groupés
les modalités de tir ça leur vocation
elles étaient plutôt
de permettre face à la prédation mais
tout en respectant le statut du loup et
bien de permettre aux éleveurs d'avoir
un certain nombre de réponses pass à à
une dynamique démographique qui qui est
augmenté monsieur le
sénateur
géré jeun je mon n ressemblait trop à r
vous m' posé la question pareil la
question sur le loup les fond de les
fronts de colonisation et le le statut
du Patou
dans le plan il y a un travail qui est
fait sur le statut du Patou parce que
aujourd'hui la responsabilité qui pèse
sur l'éleveur
est je sais pas si le mot est approprié
mais en tout cas peut paraître
disproportionné contenu de la nécessité
d'avoir un certain nombre de protection
nouvelle vu la la dynamique que nous
avons et donc la question qui se pose
c'est comment on fait évoluer le statut
du Patou aujourd'hui les travaux sont
ouverts avec le ministère de
l'agriculture sur sur cette question
mais elle est elle est pas du tout tabou
comme la question des fronts de
colonisation aujourd'hui on voit des
fronts de colonisation par des loups
solitaires on voit également un certain
nombre de
départements voir l'arrivée du loup mais
enfin il y a deux philosophies soit on
pose la question de la philosophie des
zones occupé des zones libre où on
considère que nous avons besoin de créer
de la la protection au maximum même s'il
a des territoires où effectivement la
protection au moment où on se parle
n'est pas optimal ou n'est pas nous
n'avons pas encore tous les moyens c'est
pour ça que dans le plan loup il y a
toute une partie sur les
expérimentations nouvelles alors du
létal au non létal pour être pour être
très très large euh et j'espère que la
les différentes consultations que nous
sommes en train de de mener nous apporte
enfin nous amèneront à à développer un
peu plus le sujet mais la philosophie
française c'est pas de mettre des zones
euh libre de loup et des zones occupées
c'est c'est pas celle-là c'est plutôt de
protéger au maximum même si on sait j'ai
en tête un cas en particulier je pense
euh à la zone Rockfort où la
protégeabilité réellement elle est
pas en tout cas en tout cas pas possible
en l'état et on a aussi la question des
AOP on a la question des doubles
prédations enfin la la question
aujourd'hui du loup sur les territoires
a aussi vocation je pense à être
territorialisé en partie puisque les
réponses et les besoins ne sont pas les
mêmes et on a des endroits où ça
fonctionne et on a des endroits où ça ne
fonctionne pas et on sait que les
territoires où il y a du Lot historique
benah il y a des protections qui ont
évolué et des territoires où il arrive
où les élevages sont sont beaucoup plus
sensibles et je serai évidemment au côté
sur la question de la belle de la belle
invitation qui m'a été faite pour pour
mettre en valeur notre patrimoine
charolet monsieur le Président je crois
avoir répondu aux différentes questions
que j'ai pu noter merci donc je vais
donner la parole à Michell
V monsieur le Président chers collègues
madame la ministre vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure en parlant de la SNB de
l'évaluation et des indicateurs et je
pense que je le disais lors de mon
intervention au Comité National
biodiversité où j'intervenz non pas en
tant que sénateur mais en tant que
président de la Fédération des Parcs
naturels régionaux de France je pense
que c'est important et qu'on devrait
s'obliger à un retour sur les impact des
des choix qui ont été faits et en tout
cas de de de de ce choix de cette
stratégie sur la sur la SNB euh sur le
fond euh vous avez parlé de
territorialisation et je crois que c'est
important la question c'est de savoir
comment est-ce que l'on prend en compte
euh l'impact sur les territoires et la
traduction de C SNB sur les territoires
il y a beaucoup de gestion protégé vous
les avez pas cité mais je pense que
c'est important comme de se dire que sur
les territoires nous avons les parcs
nationaux les réserves naturelles qui
interviennent les conservatoires
d'espacees naturels les grands site de
France les parcs naturels régionaux et
d'autres qui sont en réalité le dernier
maillon peut-être même le dernier
kilomètre de la mise en œuvre de cette
politique et dont il faudra tenir et
avec auquel on devra donner les moyens
vous avez parlé des moyens d'ingénerie
je la question c'est de savoir comment
est-ce que vous comptez renforcer ces
moyens à l'attention de ces
gestionnaires protéger et puis c'est
aussi la question de la cohérence de la
politique mise en œuvre en terme de
biodiversité on ne peut pas valider
simplement une stratégie nationale de la
biodiversité si parallèlement vous avez
évoqué le PACT haie si l'on constate que
le solde aujourd'hui entre les
plantations de haie et l'arrachage de de
haie reste négatif et c'est quand même
le constat que l'on fait aujourd'hui et
c'est la même chose aussi sur
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires que que l'on a sur les
les territoires enfin sur les zones
humides vous avez évoqué le projet de
parc national de zone humide si
aujourd'hui effectivement il a du mal à
sortir de terre c'est que on a tous en
mémoire ce qui s'est passé à l'époque
sur le parc national de forêt ça a été
assez compliqué sur l'acceptabilité
politique et sociale dans les territoir
proprement dit et que là on n'est pas
dans la démarche de contractualisation
avec les territoires mais bien d'une
décision qui est prise sans que l'on se
sans que les territoires considèent que
vraiment il y a une plusvalue enfin que
la dote est suffisamment intéressante
pour procè aider au au mariage et enfin
le dernier élément qui n'a encore pas
été évoqué c'est le lien qu'il y a entre
zone d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables et espace naturel et j'ai
une inquiétude de ce point de vue-là de
ce que j'entends sur les territoires de
cette volonté que quelques quelques-uns
voudraient utiliser ces zones naturelles
ces espaces naturel pour en profiter et
notamment pour l'installation notamment
des panneaux photovoltaïques vous savez
que c'est un un sujet et puis juste une
réaction sur le le loto le
loto nature et cetera moi moi je suis
assez sceptique parce que je pense que
on parle bien on l'a dit tout à l'heure
de la 6e extinction de de masse je crois
que la vie c'est pas un loto c'est pas
un jeu et donc je suis assez sceptique
alors je comprends bien qu'il y a des
moyens qui sont à la clé mais sur
l'image que cela donne sur les enjeux
liés à la biodiversité et à notre propre
avenir quant à l'espèce humaine sur
notre belle planète merci merci la
parole est à Jacques fnick oui je vais
essayer d'être rapide cette fois-ci
euh depuis le Grenel de l'environnement
si on est réfléchis bien on est sur le
même objectif général quoi en gros
stopper puis
inverser lors d'une décennie
l'effondrement du vivant en gros on n
arrive pas donc il s'agit pas avec cette
stratégie de refaire ce qui n'a pas
marché et en ce sens je crois que les
les avis du du CNPN du Comité national
de la
biodiversité sont précieux parce que moi
j'y vois leur préconisation qui se
décline en trois axes rapidement des
outils juridiques adéquats cette fois-ci
donc il faut la muscler par ces outils
juridiques adéquit il faut la financer
de façon sécurisée il faut la déployer
concrètement dans les territoires alors
sur les outils juridiques
euh alors peut-être adosser à la Charte
de l'environnement peut-être un texte
législatif mais surtout que la stratégie
soit imposée par un texte réglementaire
je crois que cette fois-ci il faut y
arriver donc mes collègues ont déjà
abordé beaucoup de ces axes donc sur le
financement j'y reviendrai pas mais sur
la articulation dans les
territoires on parlait d'un troisème
document qui traiterait de cette
déclinaison territoriale de la SNB à ma
connaissance il existe pas le Comité
national de la biodiversité n'a pas
encore vraiment commencé à à travailler
sur cette articulation entre le national
et régional donc comment déployer
concrètement efficacement cette
politique dans les
territoires merci je vais donner la
parole à Hervé Gillet merci président
pour reprendre l'intervention en
prolongation de de Jacques fernck la
planification écologique et plus
particulièrement la stratégie nationale
sur la biodiversité ne peut s'entendre
que sur une décentralisation éclairée et
sur lesquelles en l'occurrence on manque
un petit peu de d'éléments d'assurance
comment au niveau des stradet
aujourd'hui il y a ces déclinaisons
comment la politique de complémentarité
avec les ARB les agences régionales de
la biodiversité sont-elles travaillé et
comment retrouve-t-on dans les
politiques contractuelles ces objectifs
il faut donner du sens à un certain
nombre de contrats qui existent déjà des
plans comme les Plans Climat air énergie
territoriaux qui pourrai aussi avoir un
volet aujourd'hui biodiversité et en les
inscrivant dans une planification type
Scott par exemple là on en a la
possibilité ça permettrait d'avoir une
réelle vision à l'échelle des
territoires donc quelle est votre vision
sur la contractualisation la
planification et la déclinaison à
l'échelle des territoires et dernière
question il y a un sujet qui monte
aujourd'hui sur la qualité des
compensations comment évalue-t-on la
qualité des compensations aujourd'hui il
y a des interrogations qui sont fortes
parce qu'on crée des compensations mais
on ne les évalue pas réellement dans le
temps et aujourd'hui il y a de fortes
interrogations et c'est un élément
primordial par rapport à la stratégie de
la
biodiversité merci je vais donner la
parole à Andre
bellim merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues madame la ministre les autres
m abrite comme vous le savez une part
prépondérante de la biodiversité
française outre M qui sont également les
régions finalement les plus exposées au
risque et au dérèglement climatiqu et
d'ailleurs les prévisions du JEC sont
alarmantes nous concernant comme nos
prédécessurs avaient pu le rappeler lors
des débats sur la loi de la recomate de
la biodiversité les outrmèes sont
singuliers par rapport à l'Hexagone mais
également singuli par rapport entre eux-
même si je peux me permettre de le dire
comme ça et de cette observation a pu
aboutir grâce entot à une forte
mobilisation des élus ultramarins et
bien la régionalisation par bassin des
OFB les contributions à la SNB ont
amendé l'élaboration du projet de
stratégie nationale pour reconnaître une
place majeur des outresmèes dans la
biodiversité française et inclut par
ailleurs plusieurs mesures spécifiques
prévoyant nous l'espérons et bien un
réquilibrage des moyens en terme de
structuration et de monter en puissance
sur les missions qui sont définies lors
des préfigurations et bien nous devons
faire face à plusieurs enjeux trouver
les ressources humaines qualifiées afin
de répondre aux enjeux de nos
territoires et bien sûr trouver les
ressources financières pour répondre aux
enux jeu et accomplir nos missions pour
autant nous devons faire face à des
ressources financières diminuées par
rapport à l'Hexagone au regard de la
compensation de la vie chè je le
rappelle 40 % en Guadeloupe 53 % à la
Réunion et en ce qui concerne le fond
vert et bien nos arbres ne sont pas
éligibles au 100 % de subventionnement
comme pour les collectivités locales
cette question a déjà été soulevée au
sein de l'ofb et la direction générale
se dit prête à compenser cette prime et
bien si les régions apportent leur
dotation de fonctionnement aussi à même
hauteur
on est là un petit peu face à une
impasse et il faut en sortir car nous
avons à cœur nous à la réunion de lancer
de façon concertée le chantier de la
nouvelle stratégie régionale de la
biodiversité en nous appuyant sur
l'esprit de cette SNB et entre autres
sur l'agence régionale de la
biodiversité présidée par Erica baredge
peut-on attendre un financement de nos
structures à la hauteur des enjeux de la
richesse de la biodiversité et de risque
face au changement climatique je pense
notamment au fond vert où nous
souhaiterions que le subventionnement
puisse passer à 100 % aussi pour les
EPCE je vous
remercie collègue monsieur la parole est
à Monsieur Omar
Ali pas mis le micro concernant l'eau et
euh justement demander à ce qu' un
rapport complémentaire concernant les
autres mèes parce que chez nous euh la
problématique de l'eau est une réalité à
Mayotte d'où je viens bien évidemment
c'est dramatique et que si rien n'est
fait d'ici quelques temps nous allons
droit à une crise sanitaire sans
précédent dans cet î là parce que
réellement on n'a pas d'eau et déjà on
voit certaines maladies qui avaient
disparu dans l'île et qui commencent à
apparaître madame la ministre la
Commission tenonière de l'Océan Indien
s'est réunie le 21 juin 2021 a fait
constater d'une inquiétante baisse de
stock tonidé notamment le ton
albacor en raison de la surpêche dans le
canal de Mozambique dans la stratégie
nationale de la biodiversité deux fiches
proposent de limiter le changement
d'usage des terres et des mers dans
notre territoire de l'océan Indien vous
avez un bon exemple d'application de ces
orientations il faut limiter la pêche
industrielle dans le canal de Mozambique
où d'ailleurs une partie non négligeable
de ce que l'on trouve dans les filets et
rejetés à la mer les produits à forte
plusvalue N nintéresse que les
armateurs en contrepartie il faut
valoriser la perche artisanale maoraaise
qui souffre actuellement alors que son
activité est importante pour la
population locale et préserve la
ressources à la différence de la pêche
industrielle madame la ministre quelles
sont les mesures concrètes pour la pêche
artisanale de Mayotte que vous comptez
prendre sur Mayotte dans le cadre de
cette stratégie nationale de la
biodiversité vous remercier merci la
parole est à Madame finera Orte merci
président madame la ministre monsieur le
Président chers collègues alors tout
d'abord je souscris totalement à
l'intervention de la collègue de la
Réunion alors la la forêt guanaise
recèle euh la biodiversité d'une
richesse impressionnante 98 % de la
faune française est située en Guyane
depuis des années la France mène une
lutte féroce contre leorpillage illégal
sans pour autant obten obtenir des
résultats probants tous s'accordent à
dire qu'il est nécessaire de renforcer
la diplomatie et d'imposer des
contraintes économiques au Brésil d'où
viennent d'ailleurs les garemperos je
sais bien Madame la Ministre que vous
n'êtes pas ministre des Affaires
étrangères mais j'aimerais savoir quel
poids pouvez-vous avoir dans ce dossier
afin de permettre la sauvegarde de la
biodiversité guanaise vous connaissez
certainement la volonté des Guyanais à
développer leur territoire mais trop
souvent cette volonté se heurte aux
enjeux de protection environnemental
donc Madame la Ministre quelles sont les
solutions selon vous pour allier
développement durable et aménagement du
territoire voilà je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Merci monsieur
le Président Madame ministre
permettez-moi de de revenir sur deux
sujets qui ont déjà été évoqués ce matin
euh en particulier sur le milliard
d'arbres euh et et vous parlez de forêt
Méditerrané anéen
euh donc pour obtenir des des des aides
sur le fond vert il faut que les
plantations réussissent euh et donc chez
nous euh si on arrose pas une plantation
les premières années de cette plantation
la plantation elle réussit pas elle
meurt et donc les collectivités ne
s'engagent pas parce que on n pas les
moyens d'arroser l'été aujourd'hui
et donc on va aller vers une catastrophe
deuxème sujet qui est très lié à
l'évolution des des
températures les experts de l'INRA nous
disent votre forêt méditerranéenne est
depuis quelques années un stress
hydrique permanent si vous n'intervenez
pas pour amoindrir ce stress
hydrique votre forêt va dégénérer
et va se dessécher euh l'intervention
c'est quoi ben c'est d'enlever de la une
partie de la biomasse qui est pas
nécessaire à la croissance des arbres
qu'on veut voir arriver à maturité euh
et ce travail-là qui doit être fait
plusieurs fois pendant la vie de la
forêt est un travail qui coûte de
l'argent et nos forêts peu productives
ne peuvent pas supporter ça donc si on
n'a pas une aide euh pour faire ce
travail-là euh ces forêts vont
dégénérer alors ça c'est le j'ai le
premier sujet euh 2è sujet
euh euh c'est le loup qui a été euh
évoqué plusieurs fois ce matin euh et je
voudrais encore vous parler de de
spécificité euh c'est celle de l'arc
alpin euh du Var jusqu'à la Savoie euh
qui concentre aujourd'hui
euh je pense pas me tromper en disant 75
% de la pop population des
loups que nous avons en France et donc
on n pas du tout la même approche sur
ces territoires là que dans des
territoires de conquête où on voit un
loup de temps en temps nous ce sont des
meuts qui se sont installés et qui
aujourd'hui pour
moi deviennent
invasiv dans le sens où on arrive plus
à suffisamment sécuriser les éleveurs et
et les les jeunes hésitent à reprendre
les activités donc ceci ça veut dire que
les territoires vont se refermer et donc
c'est un gros impact sur la
biodiversité mais aussi sur la
biodiversité animale parce que aux
endroits où nous avons ces meuts de loup
qui se sont développés on voit
disparaître dans les alpages les
moufflon il y a plus de mouflon ça a été
le le premier animal qui a disparu
aujourd'hui
il y a une attaque en règle sur le
chamois on retrouve des chamois que dans
des dans des bars inaccessibles alors
qu' se développa un petit peu de partout
et plus en pleine ce sont les
populations de sangliers qui ont été
décimé et les populations de
chevreuil et quand on regarde ce qui se
passe aussi dans les alpages je disais
le milieu se referme mais en même temps
aujourd'hui on voit plus de
marmotte donc je pense qu'il y a un fort
impact sur la biodiversité qu'il faut
prendre en compte et ce qui m'inquiète
fortement c'est quand on voit
l'évolution de cette population de loup
sur les 10 dernières années si on
continue et qu'on laisse faire les
choses pendant encore 10 ans dans 10 ans
il y aura que les chasseurs qui pourront
aller se promener en forêt parce qu'ils
auront un fusil parce que c'est mettre
de loup il faudra qu' le continue à
manger quand il y aura plus de
population euh
sauvage merci Jean madame la mini je
vous propose de répondre on va se donner
5 minutes 58 minutes
merci merci beaucoup euh monsieur le
Président je vais essayer de tenir le
temps que vous m'accordez euh et je vais
commencer par euh monsieur le sénateur
Weber vous avez rappelé euh l'ensemble
euh de de des acteurs en tout cas qui
sont des gestionnaires des aires
protégés vous avez raison leur diversité
et euh et et leur travail est
d'exception alors pour le coup il se
trouve que dans la loi de finance 2024
on a quelque chose qui a qui a beaucoup
manqué ces 15 dernières années c'est du
recrutement humain il y a des moyens
financiers bien sûr et là pour le coup
j'en ai suffisamment parlé je pense
maisf il y a surtout une augmentation
par exemple de 15 de 15 et TP pour les
parcs le Parc National des Forêts qui
avait été créé en 2019 et on sait dans
quelle quelle histoire quelle histoire
il a eu ou encore le parc national des
calanqu et l'arrivée de TP permet aussi
d'accompagner en fait les nouveaux défis
que pose que pose ces
gestionnaires des aires protégées sur la
question des indicateurs et de la
redevabilité évidemment ça revient dans
énormément d'avis en fait des quatre
comités he si pour être très très clair
moi je suis convaincu que pour que cet
SNB fonctionne et parce que je me suis
retrouvé de l'autre côté de la table
dans quelques il y a quelques années
encore la redevabilité et le suivi des
indicateurs et de l'évaluation sera un
des éléments essentiels de cette de
cette stratégie sa planification en
terme financiers mais aussi sa
planification en terme de déploiement et
d'objectifs et c'est bien dans ce
cadrelà qu'on essaie de la faire
atterrir si vous me si vous me passez
l'expression
concernant concernant
euh le loto j'y reviendrai pas parce que
c'est pas enfin on joue pas avec la
biodiv je joue pas avec la biodive
monsieur le député monsieur sénateur
très sincèrement c'est simplement une
opportunité nouvelle comme le loto du
patrimoine de sensibiliser à un sujet
euh et rien d'autre c'est pas la
question budgétaire qui est qui est au
cœur de de ce de ce débat mais plutôt
euh comment on parle de nature bah dans
un bar PMU aussi euh sans aucune
hiérarchie dans les lieux et tout ça va
évidemment avec l'accompagnement euh de
l'éducation à l'environnement qui est
porté par les écoles par les enseignants
par les fonctionnaires euh et au sein
évidemment de de nos collectivités euh
monsieur le sénateur euh fernque vous
m'avez posé plusieurs questions euh la
question du financement bien sûr mais
surtout de la
territorialisation de de cette stratégie
nationale biodiversité sur le
financement bien sûr on parle beaucoup
de de l'argent public donc du PLF mais
aussi des moyens financiers enfin on le
dit pas assez mais mobilisé par les
collectivités que ce soit oui non non je
mais en croisant avec monsie G ça croise
parce qu'en fait il y avait la question
de la territorialisation donc en fait
j'étais entre territorialisation et
financement mais c'est mon mon
esprit est parti trop vite et je pense
qu'on met pas assez en évidence les
budgets mobilisés par les collectivités
que ce soit que ce soit les la strate
régionale départementale ou encore ou
encore communale et donc le déploiement
pour garantir ce déploiement territorial
on a vocation évidemment à mettre en
œuvre ces cops régionales mais
aujourd'hui on elles sont pas encore
lancées elles sont encore en train
d'être finalisé avec avec Christophe
Béchu et surtout de de coordonner la
stratégie réionale biodiversité pour que
la la territorialisation ne soit pas
qu'un enfin qu'un vux pieux enfin si si
pour être pour être très clair
concernant monsieur le sénateur gilet
donc là je vous reviens parce qu'il y
avait la question de territorialisation
mais il y avait la question
planification c'est la planification qui
nous donne les moyens c'est peut-être la
nouveauté mais c'est ce qui nous donne
la les moyens parce que le premier
livrable de la planification c'est
évidemment le plan haut le deuxième
livrable c'est la stratégie nationale
biodiversité le troisème livrable sera
le plan d'adaptation et donc ces trois
ces trois grands temps permettent
d'aller vers une une vers effectivement
une l'esprit de la de la
contractualisation et du coup de la
décinaison territoriale maintenant faut
c'est c'est là où la la stabilité et la
version définitive de la la stratégie
nationale devra prendre en
compte la question évidemment des ARB
mais de comment on met un volet
biodiversité à chaque fois que possible
et ça va évidemment dans notre dans
notre stradet dans nos dans dans nos
plot de gestion bien sûr mais enfin même
au-delà moi je pense évidemment au au
cobénéfice quand on a des financements
aujourd'hui qui financent les questions
par exemple d'énergie ou de climat
demain rien n'interdit d'avoir une
réflexion beaucoup plus large et
d'intégrer un peu comme un automatisme
le cobénéfice biodive et et énergie vous
avez posé la question de la qualité des
compensations c'est un énorme c'est un
énorme sujet sur lequel on travaille
d'autant plus que dans la loi dans la
loi industrie verte sur laquelle il y a
eu une une CMP conclusive on voit l'AR
arriv de de volontariat de zone de
renaturation je crois que c'est une
opportunité en or mais encore faut-il
être extrêmement vigilant quelle qualité
et quelle et qu' évaluation dans le
temps de de ces territoires donc moi je
je reste je suis très ambitieuse mais
vigilante en tout cas sur son
accompagnement madame la sénatrice
bellim vous avez raison les outremurs
dans leur diversité
apporte apporte une richesse certaine
mais il faut il faut avoir un regard
pour pour le coup plus plus spécifique
territoire par territoire puisque
au-delà de la richesse remarquable qui
est qui est
posée on a on a une stratégie nationale
biodiversité qui parce que il y a un
certain nombre de rapports et et d'avis
des comités qui ont été soulevés va
intégrer dans quasiment chacune des
fiches un regard spécifique sur la outr
mè et donc c'est les travaux que nous
sommes en train de mener pour que la
stratégie nationale présenté donc
définitive intègre bien la spécificité
des territoires mais aussi cette
particularité accompagné j'ai bien pris
note de la question du financement sur
laquelle je je pourrais revenir vous
revenir et revenir
évidemment à à la présidente de l'ARB
mais j'ai besoin de lever le sujet pour
avoir plus d'expertise sur la question
du financement et de l'arbre en
particulier monsieur le sénateur Wally
sur sur la question de la pêche de de de
mémoire sur la question de la pêche à
Mayotte ce qui est certain c'est que le
ton albacor autour de Mayotte concerne
effectivement une pêche maoraaise locale
qui officiellement je crois c'est 350
tonnes en en 2022 bah enfin il y a
encore beaucoup de barques pour le coup
non homologué qui qui cibleent les mêmes
espèces et qui du coup font une pression
certaine et puis des des navir qui
débarque jusqu'à 17000 tonnes et donc
cette pêche maoraaise elle s'effectue en
proximité mais quand il y a des des
seneurs qui opèrent dans dans dans la
région on connaît on connait la
destination de ces captures pour être
pour être très clair et donc la question
qui va se poser c'est les quotas qui
sont négociés aujourd'hui au niveau
européen mais aussi la la sécurisation
de l'activité de la pêche et de la
flottile artisanale et pour le coup
monsieur le monsieur le sénateur je sais
que ça touche particulièrement Mayotte
mais également la Réunion qui subit les
mêmes les mêmes difficultés sur l'année
de gestion 2022 en tout cas en
particulier et donc la répartition des
quotas on y sera particulièrement
vigilant et je mobiliserai également le
ministre de de la merre Hervé Berville
pour que un regard plus spécifique soit
soit porté et donc que ce
transfert soit enfin soit très soit très
suivi mais vous avez monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur également parler de
pêche durable euh et c'est et je crois
que c'est le parc marin qui met m des
actions extrêmement concrètes pour
encourager l'épaisseurs à cibler ces
espèces euh au large et euh
euh au large du lagon et enfin parce que
je pensais à ça et vous en avez parlé
vous avez raison on ne peut pas parler
de maot sans parler de la de l'eau et la
nécessité de mobiliser tous les moyens
que nous avons il se trouve que mon
ministère même s'il arrive dans un dans
un deuxième volet au-delà de la crise
immédiate que vit Mayotte a fléché 35
millions d'euros supplémentaires euh sur
sur la question des des oututres mèes
parce que la priorité c'est évidemment
le maintien de cette de cette cellule de
crise interministérielle au quotidien on
ne peut pas avoir des compatriotes qui
n'ont pas euh qui vivent cette crise
historique de sécheresse mais qui
aujourd'hui impactent leur quotidien
d'accès à l'eau potable bien sûr mais
enfin on sait vous en avez parlé des
questions sanitaires qui en découlent et
on a évidemment nous espérons tous voir
la pluie et et l'arrivée aussi des eau
qui sont été envoyé depuis depuis
l'hexagone mais pour sécuriser de
manière pérenne l'approvisionnement
d'eau potable la question des
infrastructures et des investissements
nécessaires est posé aujourd'hui et je
pense qu'il faut la poser sans tabou
pour mettre les investissements en tout
cas pour pour pour
Mayotte enfin pas non avant avant
dernière question madame la sénatrice h
sur la forêt guyanaise il se trouve que
j'ai eu la
chance sous avec mon ancienne cetettete
au ministère des armées d'avoir d'avoir
l'opportunité de voir la richesse de la
Guyane et les dégâts que font que fait
leur paayage
illégal tout sens confondu socialement
écologiquement et à quel point ça coûte
encore la vie d'hommes et de femme qui
protège en réalité cette cette
magnifique cette magnifique forêt madame
la sénatrice ce qui est ce qui est
certain c'est que la Guyane au-delà
d'être un poumon et un trésor de
biodiversité les enjeux qui qui qui sont
aujourd'hui en Guyane sont comment on
peut développer plus et pour ça c'est la
même c'est la même réponse il faut
territoire par territoire la spécificité
de de la Guyane est particulière et donc
vous me trouverez à vos côtés chacun
avec la spécificité évidemment du
territoire pour accompagner une
stratégie bien locale et monsieur le
sénateur pour conclure bati alors vous
avez parlé du milliard d'arbres sur la
question des essence et la question de
la biomasse sur laquelle je pourrais
revenir et puis vous avez insisté sur la
question du loup
et de et de et de la prédation du lot en
particulier mais dans une zone pour le
coup
historique le
le le sujet le plus le plus important
aujourd'hui qu'il faudra un moment
apaiser c'est la question du comptage
puisque on parlait du nombre euh
aujourd'hui nous prélevons 19 % de la
population de loup sur sur notre sur
notre territoire mais les plus grandes
difficultés en tout cas les plus grands
questionnements se posent sur combien
nous avons de loup sur notre territoire
et donc combien de prélèvement
euh c'est les travaux que nous avons
ouverts entre les différents les
différentes parties prenantes pour avoir
ne plus avoir deux chiffres un avant
l'été un après l'été qui crée du trouble
dans dans l'opinion même si ce sont deux
méthodes le comptage ce sont deux
comptages qui ont qui sont renforcés
d'ailleurs par la question par un par
une analyse génétique vous avez aussi
soulevé la question des de la reprise
d'un certain nombre d'élevage et de la
pression qui est faite franchement quand
je vois des éleveurs les éleveurs me
disent pas mon sujet c'est
l'indemnisation c'est le transformation
de leur métier l'impact sur leur vie
familiale enfin c'est c'est c'est c'est
parfois des drames humains en tout cas
sur les exploitations qui sont vécu mais
ce qui est certain c'est que il faut
faciliter ces ces indemnisations quand
même et donc dans le plan dans le plan
loup et dans les groupe de travaux nous
avons posé la question et l'opportunité
par exemple d'une télédéclaration qui
simplifie pour alléger aussi la vie au
quotidien d'un certain nombre
d'éleveurs vous avez parlé de l'impact
du LOU sur la biodiversité enfin c'est
aussi un les grands prédateurs sont
aussi on aussi des impacts positifs sur
la biodiversité donc la question c'est
comment finalement nous pouvons évaluer
l'apport du loup en terme de
biodiversité et comment nous pouvons
aussi évaluer l'apport du pastoralisme
en terme de biodiversité il se trouve
que j'ai été auditionné à l'Assemblée
nationale par le
groupe le groupe pastoralisme et on est
en train de travailler sur peut-être la
saisine d'une inspection conjointe pour
réfléchir
à comment accompagner finalement un
regard posé sur les bénéfices ou les
cobénéfices évidemment et du
pastoralisme et de la et de la et du et
du prédateur et Monsieur le monsieur le
sénateur pour pour
conclure j'espère bien en tout cas que
non n'y aura pas seulement des chasseurs
qui pourront se promener dans nos
magnifiques territoires parce que plus
que jamais nous avons besoin
d'accompagner tout le monde et de
préserver une espèce qui est aujourd'hui
encore menacée je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président merci Madame la
Ministre moi je je tiens vraiment à vous
remercier parce que euh les questions
étaient denses et beaucoup de nos
collègues qui qui sont intervenus ça ça
ça prouve tout l'intérêt que porte cette
commission à la biodiversité et moi je
suis heureux des échanges qu'on a pu
avoir et euh des réponses que vous avez
pu nous apporter euh merci et on aura
l'occasion effectivement de nouveau
d'échanger sur sur un certain nombre de
dossiers j'ai j'ai bien conscience que
cette problématique du loup est une
problématique importante et euh pour
pour pour terminer AC un petit peu
d'humour euh Jean tu as de la chance
parce que chez toi et ben ils attaquent
les les
sangliers chez moi euh ils trouvent que
ils ont plus près dans le frigo et ils
attaquent nos B belliardes donc voilà
merci madame la ministre pour
effectivement cet
échange